while chancellor olaf schultz is in
washington germany's foreign minister
annalina balbach will be in kiev for two
days of high-level talks she'll be
joined there by her czech slovak and
austrian counterparts
our correspondent matthias berlinga is
in the ukrainian capital matthias
germany is not giving ukraine any
weapons to defend itself in the case of
a russian invasion kiev has expressed
deep frustration over this what can
germany's foreign minister do to show
berlin support for ukraine
well that's a very good question we've
heard it again germany is not going to
deliver little weapons germany has
however delivered helmets and
a field hospital or a promised field
hospital
and
which has been mocked a little bit in
the in the western defense community and
also in ukraine but germany has to do
something if they don't want to see be
seen as an unreliable partner well it's
one of the biggest uh uh
countries in terms of foreign aid to
ukraine this uh discussion about weapons
that has not been uh uh
uh led very very aptly by germany in the
in the last few
uh weeks uh has really harmed germany's
image here and also in central
europe and one thing that germany could
probably do without um
uh
without violating this uh self-stated
principle that they never deliver
weapons to crisis regions would be to
unblock weapon deliveries from other
countries from other nato countries who
are waiting for germany's consent to
deliver weapons for example that are of
german manufacturing
matias uh germany's foreign minister
analina balbach she'll be joined in kiev
by her czech slovak and austrian
counterparts what's their role there
well as
what this shows us is that their concern
is really high in many countries in
europe about what's going on here and
the countries who obviously watch this
very closely are the countries bordering
uh ukraine like slovakia like poland uh
and uh these countries do not have a uh
unanimous stance on the on the crisis
austria is leaning more towards the
german position to diplomacy they also
have very good relations with russia
economic deep economic relations with
russia while the eastern
eu member states are much more uh
wary are much more
aware of a russian threat and uh lean
more towards the western towards the
american position
now i i know materials that you've just
come back from eastern ukraine you're
there near areas controlled by
russian-backed separatists he visited a
village i understand right at the front
line let's take a look at your report
now
the village school of granite the last
village here on ukrainian controlled
territory is close to the front line it
has come under fire before
now the classrooms are empty not because
of the war but because of new covet
restrictions the war is something people
here have been living with for eight
years
we go to work and most of the time the
children go to school
but we don't know what will happen
in five or ten minutes
or tomorrow night
we're always worried always scared
just a few hundred meters down this road
is the last ukrainian position this
school is in the line of fire of the
opposite side
there is a heavy military presence in
granite
a ceasefire is in place but shelling can
sometimes
it was worse a few years ago we always
hid in the cellar when there was
fighting
but that was then
but with the latest russian buildup a
bigger escalation is on the table again
when things come down we bought a house
here
but now we don't know what will happen
ukrainian territory ends with the last
houses of the village
behind a small river lies a
demilitarized strip
the pedestrian bridge is the only link
to the next village in the so-called
gray zone
the next village is not small people
come here every day to work and kids go
to school
one of the people who crosses the border
every day is teacher ludmila kaczuk she
is from across the river and does not
want to give her real name because her
life depends on good relations with both
sides
shelling is even more frequent in her
village
my work is here
i come here every day
yes it's hard
yes it's dangerous very dangerous
but i cannot just quit work and leave i
just can't
she says she has not yet lost hope that
somehow this conflict might come to an
end peacefully
mathias the teacher we just saw in your
report there she seems determined to
stay uh how do the other people there
feel about the russian troop build up
and what are they expecting moving
forward
well i mean everybody who's still there
is determined to stay everybody who
wanted to leave or had the opportunity
to leave
has already left of course
i think
people are following the news very
closely and are quite afraid of uh of uh
this situation right now um they have
experienced war for eight years and uh
that most of them must have said that
they just hope that somehow there will
be a solution to this situation what we
have there is that people who live there
might have relatives on the other side
they cannot travel some of them have not
seen their relatives um
at the other board side of the border
some have children that one man said he
has a son in moscow and
a daughter in mariopol on the ukrainian
side so these families are torn apart by
this war
matthias thank you very much uh for your
reporting matthias berlinga there dw's
correspondent in kia